[Musique]
une journée nationale consacrée aux
assistants maternels pour la réunion
c'était au village corail que c'était
réunit professionnels partenaires
institutionnels et le public pour
échanger sur les différents modes de
garde et le métier d'assistant maternel
le département de la réunion délivre
l'agrément qui permet d'exercer ce
métier mais également les formations
obligatoires
le département a l'obligation de les
dispenser une formation de base qui est
d'une durée de 120 heures mais mal et
qui va se dérouler en deux parties donc
une première partie 80 heures juste
après son agrément avant quelques débute
sa fonction des soins maternels avant
l'accueil du premier enfant et une
seconde partie de 40 heures qui sera
dispensé après deux ans à trois ans
d'exercice à la réunion ils sont 1800
assistants maternels qui offrent près de
5600 places d'accueil différents modes
de garde sont proposées à leur domicile
chez les parents et en maisons
d'assistants maternels jeunes en accueil
collectif pour les enfants mon coup nous
échanger avec nos collègues échanger
avec les par brand
on peut se remettre en question peut
évoluer et en même temps on a un accueil
collectif pour les enfants mais un
accueil aussi individuelle qui est très
important une conférence sur les
troubles de l'oralité alimentaire a été
animée par le syndicat des
orthophonistes un moment des changes
associé à la notion plus générale de la
prévention chez des jeunes qu'il faut
revenir beaucoup plus vers la politique
de prévention les politiques de
prévention aux toits des grossesses
précoces auto à des addictions au toit
des violences faites à la tire de la
famille parfois quand les enfants
eux-mêmes et donc surtout cela nous
devons agir à voir ce qu'on aura plus de
moyens
j'espère qu'on aura quand même de
meilleurs résultats
[Musique]